titanfall 2 is happening in other news  the sky is blue but hey at least we got  a teaser trailer I'm Tony and this is  your fully mechanized gamespot news  update the short video features a  voiceover discussing what it means to be  a hero while a Titan approaches a drop  pod that bears the name James McAllen a  name you might recognize from the first  game the Titan then stabs an EHR  titanium series sword into the ground so  it looks like blades are coming to the  sequel as a new weapon type but you  should still definitely expect the guns  and mech suits and parkour that the  first game had EA has a full titanfall  to reveal planned for june twelfth  that's the day of the publishers pre e3  press conference at the very least we  know the game will be out by the end of  March 2017 and that it's coming to ps4  xbox one and pc keep your sights on  gamespot and we'll tell you all about  titanfall 2 as soon as we hear more